welcome back to Las Vegas now if you're
looking for a cool way to celebrate
Valentine's Day we might have the thing
for you Chef Jeff Jackson from Smith's
Food and Drugs the sponsors of this
segment is showing us how to make
delicious icy treats no Churn ice cream
hello everybody I'm Chef Jeff from
Smith's now you may have noticed I used
a lot of simple truth products in my
cooking that's because they're high
quality and I love them they're an
organic product that Smith uses but
they're not super expensive like you
would expect for organic things and
that's why I love it so much my friend
Tina Morrison from Smith is going to
explain that in a little more detail
thank you Jeff it is great to be here
with you today yeah it is simple truth's
10th anniversary and Smith's introduced
this fantastic product to offer our
customers a high quality products at an
affordable price Simple Truth products
are free from all of those artificial
colors flavors preservatives and
sweeteners and the and the Growers grow
these products not using the synthetic
fertilizers and genetic engineering that
people don't want I know I don't want
that stuff but so it's happy birthday to
the simple truth we're going to make
homemade ice cream using using simple
truth products all the way okay so we're
making ice cream without an ice cream
makers which is what makes this recipe
so fun ice cream churners or the
machines put air into the product we
already did that by whipping some cream
which we did earlier so we whipped cream
to simple to stiff peaks okay so we need
to flavor our ice cream let's get some
sweetened condensed milk and pour in our
Bowl I'm going to be making a rocky road
version you're going to be making what
which one were you gonna do 50's and
cream I'm so excited everybody loves
family favorite so basically we're going
to do the base first and then we'll add
the flavorings after that so we've got
sweetened condensed milk we've got salt
and then we've got vanilla so once you
get all that in just go ahead and whisk
it together
okay so just until that comes together
I'm going to put cocoa powder in mine to
make my rocky road so I'm going to be
chocolate you're going to be vanilla so
we both have our bases ready to go
okay let me get that mixed together it
takes just a second okay so we've got
our bases ready now let's get our
whipped cream in there take about a just
a cup of it and then mix it together
have you ever folded whipped cream into
something before right so the idea is
that we don't kill that air that we've
that we've put into the whipped cream so
just fold it around gently now take that
entire thing and put it into the larger
bowl of whipped cream and then we're
going to just fold that all together and
then that's going to be the base of our
ice cream so just get it in there and
just fold away and then we'll get them
so they're all mixed and looking
beautiful
okay it's time to flavor I've got my
Rocky Road you got your cookies and
cream just go ahead and fold those in
I'm doing almonds and uh marshmallow
you're doing the cookies so for once
you've mixed that it goes into a loaf
pan a nine inch loaf pan and then you're
gonna cover that with plastic you're
gonna put it in the fridge or not the
fridge but freezer for about three to
four hours and then cover it with
plastic and then we have finished one I
have mine here you've got yours there
let's see how we did this looks
beautiful yeah look at that scoop
delicious it looks awesome so a simple
truth products you can find them at any
local store they're awesome product I
love them you can find them at your
local Smiths thanks for watching thanks
for shopping we'll see you next time bye
everyone
and our thanks to Smith's Food and Drug
for sponsoring this segment if you'd
like more information just go to their
website at smithsfoodanddrug.com